dites ce que vous m'avez dit je l'ai
[Musique]
tué Daniel g j l merci de me recevoir
j'enquête sur un appel
téléphoniquee ilessé de tuer qu'est-ce
que je peux faire c'est au sujet d'une
ancienne affaire sur laquelle vous avez
travaillé il y atemps mon pe ami il lui
a donné des coups de
couteau vous êtes au courant qu'il a
avoué imagine qu'il est innocent cette
enquête a été diligentée de façon
juste qu'est-ce qu'il a caché laissez-le
tranquille
Garti est un des
[Musique]
meilleurs certaines choses ne
s'apprennent pas et parfois si on décide
d'aller plus loin il n'y a aucune honte
à ça on a eu le coupable non vous avez
eu des aveux on doit couvrir nos
arrières elle nous colle vraiment
il cherche la bagarre apparemment c'est
dans mes cordes c'est lui que j'ai vu tu
es une victime
collatérale connaissez-vous la
différence entre l'ordre et le chaos
vous allez m'en
empêcher
[Musique]
exact